Снігу в Німеччині випадає менше, ніж в Україні,
але й він часом завалює німецькі вулиці й автобани.
Якщо переважна більшість німців мріє
про "біле" Різдво і Новий рік,
то для муніципальних служб сніг на міських вулицях -
це в першу чергу "сміття", тож його слід якнайшвидше прибрати
і подбати, щоб на вулицях не було ожеледиці.
Хто, коли і як його чистить?
У Німеччині на все є свої правила.
За міські дороги відповідають спеціальні
зимові муніципальні служби. Додатково можуть залучати
також приватні фірми. Коли очікується снігопад,
ці служби переходять на посилений режим роботи.
Чергові бригади, оснащені спеціальною технікою,
в разі необхідності можуть працювати цілодобово:
у дві або три зміни. До речі, оплата праці в нічний час,
вихідні та святкові дні, зокрема, на Різдво чи Новий рік,
удвічі, а то й утричі вища, ніж у звичайний робочий день.
До боротьби зі снігом і ожеледицею в зимовий період
співробітників готують ще влітку.
Проводяться спеціальні курси і тренування,
на яких їх не тільки вчать керувати снігоочисною технікою,
а й що робити в екстрених ситуаціях. Крім того,
водії снігоочисних машин повинні добре орієнтуватися
в місті, щоб швидко добиратися до "слизьких" точок.
Робочий день у борців зі сніговим "сміттям"
при мінусовій температурі починається
о четвертій ранку в будні й о 6-й на вихідних.
В першу чергу розчищають від снігу
головні транспортні артерії міста і мости.
Для цього існує спеціальний, продуманий до найменших деталей
план пріоритетності. У ньому враховано
важливі транспортні розв'язки, небезпечні перехрестя,
під'їзди до лікарень, маршрути громадського транспорту,
особливо на підйомах або спусках.
Потім на черзі "звичайні" міські вулиці.
Але тут працювати доводиться і самим німцям.
За законом, за чистоту тротуарів відповідають
власники прилеглих до них будинків або орендарі квартир.
Тротуар повинен бути вільним від снігу та льоду
з 7 години ранку до 8 вечора в звичайні дні
і з 9 ранку у вихідні. Причому йдеться
не про вузькі стежинки, на яких і двом перехожим не розійтися,
а про смугу мінімум півтора метри шириною.
Якщо хтось зламає ногу, послизнувшись на заледенілому тротуарі,
або йому на голову впаде з даху бурулька, то медичні послуги,
як і інші витрати, пов'язані з травмою, оплачує власник будинку.
Точніше, його страховка.
Посипати сіллю тротуари в Німеччині заборонено,
за винятком хіба що екстрених ситуацій.
На це є багато причин: це шкодить довкіллю, небезпечно для міських тварин,
засолює підземні води, спричиняє корозію автомобілів,
роз'їдає взуття перехожих.
Альтернатива солі - гравій, щебінь або пісок.
Їх можна придбати в будь-якому магазині
будівельних або господарських товарів.
До речі, на зупинках громадського транспорту,
а також на підходах до них - сходах, спусках, підйомах -
за розчищення снігу і льоду відповідають
комунальні транспортні підприємства, а на вокзалах - залізниця.
Для безпеки дорожнього руху взимку
важливо підготувати не лише дороги, але й автомобілі.
Правило номер один: шини.
Вони мусять бути зимові або щонайменше всесезонні.
Якщо водій потрапляє в аварію на літній гумі в зимовий час,
страхова компанія може відмовитися покривати збитки.
Важливо також, щоб шини не були "лисими".
Висота профілю має бути не менше 4 міліметрів.
Водіям рекомендують також подбати
про фари на машині:
чи всі вони справні,  чи  правильно налаштовані, чи не сліплять.
Слід перевірити наявність антифризу в охолоджувачі
та в рідині для очищення скла. А також
справність акумуляторів, щоб автомобіль завівся на морозі.
Автомайстерні навіть пропонують
спеціальну послугу з підготовки автівки до зими:
так званий "вінтерчек". Машину перевірять
за майже 10 різними позиціями.
Вартість такої послуги - 15-20 євро.
Перед тим, як рушати, водії мають очистити авто від снігу та льоду.
Це важливо не лише для безпеки самого водія,
але й інших автомобілів,  щоб на них не впали
заледенілі шматки снігу.
На ожеледі німцям рекомендують їздити
на другій швидкості, уникати різких поворотів руля
чи різкого гальмування. А також обов'язково
тримати дистанцію до автівки попереду.
Найкраща порада в період зимових пробок:
не нервувати, а виїжджати на роботу із достатнім запасом часу.